Jeff:
Okay, thank you.
Welcome everyone.
Thank you for joining
"Developing Innovative
Custom Business Solutions
with Google Apps".
My name is Jeff Ragusa.
I look after the channel program
for Google Apps,
and I'm going to be joined
in a bit by David Hoff
from Cloud Sherpas,
who's one of our partners,
who's done quite a bit
of work in this area.
So what are we
talking about?
Specifically in this session,
we're talking about developing
solutions for business customers
who are also customers
of Google Apps;
and we're talking
about customization,
so custom solutions to fit
a particular business use case.
So those are
the underlying threads.
Some things that I would
like you to take away:
#1 is that developers have
the tools to be quite flexible
in terms of the business
solutions
that they are able to create
for their customers,
and with a little creativity,
are really in power to solve
a wide variety of business
problems with those customers.
#2, customizations
can be lightweight,
lightweight in terms of the
investment required to ramp up,
and in terms of
the investment required
to actually develop
customizations,
but then we can also
attack more complex
enterprise scenarios as well,
so it really depends
on the problem at hand,
the nature of the problem,
and how much energy investment
you want to put into it.
And then #3,
there's a business here.
So I mentioned I look after
the partner program.
We'll talk about
our partners
and we'll talk about the role
that they play here.
And when I say partners,
I'm talking about third party
integrators and developers.
But you don't have to be
a partner to partake
and for this
to be useful.
Certainly you can be
a developer
and end user
at a Google Apps organization
to extend and customize
your Google Apps instance.
So, brief agenda.
We're going to set the table and
talk about a brief background
on Google Apps,
and then we'll talk about
the bigger picture IT landscape
that this all fits into,
and then we'll talk
about our partners
and the landscape there
and the role that they play,
then we'll talk about
some of the tools
that are typically
used to customize
and integrate Google Apps.
And we're not going to go
too much in depth on the tools.
There are sessions at Google IO
that dive into each of the tools
that I'm going to talk about
in more depth.
I just wanted to
briefly touch on them
and really give an idea of the
breadth of possibilities here.
And then we're going
to intersperse
that with discussions
of some examples
of what we're seeing
in the wild,
and particularly for
illustrative purposes,
we'll use our partners
and some of the experiences
that they've had
with their customers.
And then, as mentioned,
David will come up,
and will go more in depth
into an example,
that Cloud Sherpas--a scenario
that Cloud Sherpas recently had
with one of their customers.
So let's talk about
Google Apps.
What is Google Apps?
To level set, Google Apps is our
suite of business applications
for providing employees
powerful messaging
and collaboration tools.
So, as a set of tools,
it's really anchored
on the messaging/communications
side by Gmail,
which acts as the communications
hub for users.
And then it's anchored
on the collaboration side
by Google Docs
and Google Sites,
which acts as
a collaboration umbrella,
often for teams
and projects and so forth.
So, a set of other tools,
all hosted by Google,
and then accessible
by end users and customers
through their web browser
or any web-capable device.
What I want to talk about
specifically for developers--
a couple points.
First, there's a ton
of users on this.
Over 3 million businesses
using Google Apps today,
and comprising over
30 million active end users.
So you have an audience
here as a developer,
and it's a rapidly
growing audience.
Also, this suite as a platform
is growing pretty rapidly,
so we released
218 features last year,
and many of these are related
to the developer interfaces
and tools that are available
to you.
And then
there's a 99.9% uptime SLA,
so what this means
for developers is,
you can hitch your wagon
to Google Apps,
and not have to worry
so much about the reliability
of your dependent components,
which is important.
So if you want to learn more
or get an account,
learn more about Google Apps,
google.com/a.
Another piece of the puzzle
here is, about two years ago,
we launched a channel program
around this,
and because of the economics
of Google Apps,
this was really
designed to attract
service-oriented partners
who were really involved
in handling all aspects
of the customer life cycle.
And the design point
of the program
is really to enable partners
and facilitate partners
to be able to be the face
of the technology
and the face of the innovation
for their customers.
And so we've seen partners
embrace this role,
and use that to create
comprehensive solutions
for their customers
involving multiple products
and multiple vendors,
and then pulling those
together into solutions,
and then providing consulting
and support around that.
And then, more recently,
what we're seeing is a trend
toward adding custom development
into the mix,
where they're building
their development skills,
and then using that to integrate
and extend the solutions
that they're able to create.
And I think this is where
the IO audience in particular
is going to be able to play
a part and get a leg up.
So you want to partake or
learn more about the partner
program around Google Apps,
google.com/apps/resellers.
Okay.
And then the last piece of
the puzzle here is our vision,
really, for where we see
businesses going.
In this world, it's what
we refer to as 100% web.
It's really this world
where applications and data
are stored centrally,
and then served out
over a scale-able,
multi-teneted infrastructure,
delivered out
over the Internet,
and then consumed by users
purely through a web browser.
And so, this vision really
allows the young customer
and their partners, frankly,
to be able to focus
on the specific logic
and processes
to separate that business
and move that business forward.
We have a set of tools
to support this vision.
I talked a little bit
about Google Apps,
on the left-hand side there,
as a suite of applications
that you can buy from Google.
Over on the right hand side
in the form of
the Google Apps Marketplace,
we have a marketplace of
third party web applications,
over 300 vendors,
and these are web applications
that are already integrated
in with Google Apps
in various ways.
And there's a session,
I believe,
right before this in here,
that went into depth
on the marketplace
and how to leverage that.
But then in the middle you have,
customers are able to create
custom applications,
using the various tools
of our development platform.
This is where I'm going
to spend the majority
of the rest of the time here.
We have all
these applications
on this web platform, served up
using HTML as a platform,
and then with Chrome
and Android and Chrome OS,
we provide the tools to be able
to access these applications
from anywhere
and any device.
So you put those together,
and we have our developers
and the resellers,
and our partner,
and now we're really
in a prime position
to drive customers toward
this 100% web vision,
and they're really playing
at least three roles in this.
First, they're playing
the traditional role
of value-added reseller,
or managed service provider,
and this involves bringing
Google Apps
as an application suite
to their customers,
and implementing
and providing consulting
and support around that,
as well as sourcing
complementary applications,
from other vendors,
for example,
from the marketplace,
and then building multi-vendor
solutions there.
Secondly, they're playing
the role of systems integrator,
where they're using
the development tools
of our platform to create
the custom logic
and custom interfaces to tie
together applications
from Google and third parties
into comprehensive solutions.
And then, third,
they're playing the role
of the independent
software vendor,
using those same
developer tools
and building stand-alone
applications.
So what we're seeing is a trend
where former pure-play VARs,
or service providers,
are expanding their business,
they're growing
their developers' skills,
and they're starting by creating
custom integration practices
and custom development
practices,
and then some of them
are starting
to productize
that work as well.
And there's recurring
revenue opportunities
across each
of these roles.
Okay. So let's talk now about,
what are the tools?
So the tools that we're seeing
typically used by customers to--
by partners and developers
to provide custom logic
and then integrate that
into Google Apps
and create custom solutions.
We'll look at it from the lens
of looking at Google Apps,
and then examining the ways
in which you can customize
and extend.
So one of the first things
you need to do,
or one of the things
is to create
custom business logic.
So an example here would be
if you want to code up
a custom business process--
so, for example,
approval work flow for procuring
office supplies.
So a couple different tools
that we see typically used:
one is Google App Engine,
which is a full stack
for developing and hosting
web applications,
and another
is Google Apps Script,
which is a lightweight
scripting framework.
Both of these provide
the ability to host
and develop custom logic
on Google infrastructure,
and then from there, being able
to do various things.
Another--and we're going to
dive into these tools
and go into some examples--
but another thing
that you'll
often need to do
is to create
a custom user interface.
So in the procurement work
flow example,
what you need to do is an
employee needs to be able to go
somewhere to browse the tools,
to browse what's available,
and then to make
procurement requests.
So we've got--and this could be
stand-alone user interfaces,
or it could be custom--
it could be actually integrated
in within the Google Apps
user experience.
So a couple tools here,
or sets of options here.
One is Gadgets, so Gadgets are
HTML and JavaScript components
that are portable,
and you're able to customize
your user interface there.
Another is Google Web Toolkit,
which is a toolkit
for creating more complex,
interactive UI components.
Another thing you'll want
to be able to do is
you'll want to integrate
with Google Apps,
at the data layer,
and be able to actually modify
and manipulate the business
objects underlying Google Apps.
And Apps Script can
certainly help you here,
and we'll talk about
some examples there,
but then also there is
a set of Google data APIs
that pertain specifically
to Google Apps,
and allow you to read
and write business objects
under Google Apps.
And then finally,
you want to bring together
a more seamless
experience for users.
You really need to integrate
on the administrative level
as well, and so you want
to be able to share
a common language
around a user account store,
common authentication
systems,
and if you have property pages
or other ways of configuring
your customizations,
then you want that to be tied in
to the Apps administrative
experience as well.
So we'll talk
about these things.
We'll start on the custom
business logic layer.
So you saw this yellow icon
appearing a bunch
in that graphic.
So that speaks to the power
and flexibility of Apps Script,
and it's really lightweight
and easy to learn.
I think it's one of the reasons
that we're seeing our partners
gravitate toward it.
So Apps Script is a
cloud-scripting framework,
standard JavaScript,
executed on the server side.
It provides the flexibility
to automate business logic
and multi-step work flows
across products.
So what can you do, briefly,
with Apps Script?
Well first, you can host
custom logic, as I mentioned.
If you can code something up
in JavaScript,
then you're off
and running there.
Next thing is, you want to be
able to trigger that logic,
so you can create
custom user interface
panels using Apps Script,
and then surface those panels
through something
like Google Sites,
one of the applications.
And then from there,
capture user information
and validate the user inputs
and so forth.
Another thing you want
to be able to do
is to modify and integrate
with Google Apps,
and so with Apps Script, and
again these are JavaScript APIs,
you can interact
with Google Sites,
be able to create
sites and pages,
Google Docs, be able to update
spreadsheet cells,
update a user's
Google calendar,
and so on and so forth.
And then, this can also go
the other direction,
so you can respond
to event triggers.
So for example,
within a spreadsheet form,
you can actually trigger
your Apps Script logic
that way as well.
And then, you also,
with Apps Script,
you're able to interact
with Internet services
outside of
the Google Apps realm,
so be able to send HTTP
requests, and send email,
make web service requests,
and so forth.
So we'll look
at a couple examples,
and then we'll look at
some of the other technologies.
So Revevol is one of
our early Google Apps partners,
and as they built up
their operation,
they found that they were
providing this service
of training customers,
and they wound up having to
schedule a volume
of these training sessions.
And each training session
would be in a specific location
with a specific trainer,
and specific trainer skill sets,
a language,
and a time and so forth.
And so they put out a form
to capture this information,
to capture requests from users,
but then what happened was
they had to manually respond
to those form requests,
and match up
and find trainers.
So what they did was
they addressed this
with Google Apps Script,
end to end.
First they used the UI
component creation features
to be able to create
a custom form, as we see here,
actually surfaced
that in a Google site.
But this form allows
a requester to go in
and request a trainer.
The Apps script is then behind
that "show trainers" button,
and then what that does is
it does a look-up
into a spreadsheet,
which effectively acts
as a database of trainers.
So you've got Apps Script
creating the UI,
and doing the look-up.
And then in response to that,
what they do is they show
a list of results
on the left-hand side,
an interactive list display,
and because there's address
information in there,
they're able to
also show that on a map,
so both of these user
interface panels
and the integration
with maps,
all done using Apps Script.
And then the user is
able to select a subset
of those trainers
and send a proposal to them,
and of course sending
a proposal, in this case,
manifests itself
as adding an event
to that trainer's
Google Calendar.
So a really nice example tying
together multiple products,
and all of the logic
and the work flow
and the user interface
components behind this
are all built using
Apps Script.
Another example: Newmind Group
is another one of our partners,
with Google Apps,
and they've seen success
going vertical into
the construction industry.
And one of the issues they have
in the construction industry
is coordination between
subcontractors and contractors,
and particularly, example
around coordinating deliveries.
And of course, traditionally
this is done offline.
So, Newmind decided to tackle
this with their client,
Wadman Corporation.
What they did was, again,
they created a custom form,
which they actually created
Google sites
for each of the construction
job projects,
and then they pushed
this form out,
and it allows the subcontractor
to go in there
and submit a request.
The form, the UI,
is powered by Apps Script,
and then when you go ahead
and make a request,
using more script,
it sends out notifications
to the general contractor
with a link back
to this approval queue,
which is another custom UI
created using Script.
The general contractor
comes in
and is able to view
the deliveries,
what's pending
and what's been approved,
is able to modify
the request,
and then go ahead
and approve the delivery.
And again, there's Apps Script
behind this,
and basically
once it approves,
it sends notifications
in both directions,
and then also updates
the shared delivery schedule.
So another nice example
of Apps Script on the UI side,
and of the logic behind it.
Another example: Knowledge
and Innovation Networks.
This is a member community
that uses Google Sites
to share documents and share
event information amongst
their member community,
and they hold about 30 or 40
of these events per year.
And so, what they had was--
Phil Ridout
is a consultant for them,
and he saw this
and decided,
"There has to be a better way
of handling the event promotion
and registration,
versus the manual,
error-prone process
that they were using."
And the interesting point here
is that Phil had
no JavaScript experience,
so he had to learn
everything on the fly,
including
the base language.
So what he did was he created
this spreadsheet template,
which allows event organizers
to go in,
and he was able to capture
event information
in a structured way.
And then, he added a custom
menu item on the spreadsheet.
So this is powered
by Apps Script,
so you can actually customize
and add menu items
to a spreadsheet.
And that menu item allows
an event organizer--
again, in a standardized
way across events--
to be able to take
the event information
and create a brand new Google
Sites landing page
for the event,
take the event information
and push it
to an event calendar,
and then push out to an
announcement feed for the event.
And then he's able to handle
event confirmation emails,
and event reminder emails,
and so forth.
So, a really nice example,
and again, you know,
this was Phil's starter project
to run JavaScript.
Okay, so leaving Apps Script,
the other place that you can
create custom logic
and host custom logic,
of course,
is App Engine.
So, App Engine is all about
fast and easy development
and deployment of
web applications,
simple administration.
There are both Java and Python
run-time environments,
which allows you as a developer
to take advantage
of the common libraries
and tools and frameworks
created for those environments.
But then, and similar
to Apps Script,
it allows you to leverage
Google accounts
for authentication
and for authorization.
So what you can do is you
can create your custom logic,
your custom application;
you can restrict access
to the individual users
or individual employees
of a particular customer.
And then, like Apps Script,
you can interact
with web services and email
and HTTP requests and so forth.
So developers typically
have a choice,
and often you can use one
or the other of these tools.
The way I look at it is,
Apps Script is a little bit
more lightweight,
and App Engine is a little bit
more flexible.
So one example is, if you have
the need to create statefulness
in your custom application, and
persist state across requests,
App Engine or Persista,
in-memory caching
and that kind of thing,
App Engine will give you
a little bit more flexibility
there.
So we'll talk about a simple
App Engine example in a second,
but I want to flip up
to the UI layer,
and at the UI kind of
building block layer,
we have Google Web Toolkit.
And Web Toolkit is an
open-source toolkit
for building
web application UIs,
and it's really optimized
for performance
and for browser compatibility.
And the interesting thing
here is,
an increasing number
of Google properties
are actually using
Web Toolkit.
So, Google engineers are
using this, underlying,
to be able to create
their own UIs.
Now, I showed this
right after App Engine,
because if you're using
the Java version of App Engine,
this is a really
convenient tool,
and a lot of our Enterprise
developers are skilled
with Java,
but with Web Toolkit,
what it allows you to do is
you're actually developing
your UI in Java,
and then compiling
that down to JavaScript.
So the end distribution
is JavaScript in HTML,
but the development
environment is Java,
and there's actually a plug-in
for Eclipse that allows you
to be able to develop your
client project in Web Toolkit,
and then right alongside
your server,
say, Google App Engine Java
project,
and then be able to not only
have a nice, consistent
development environment,
but also be able to debug,
and it's a really neat way of
doing client server debugging.
So, a simple example that ties
in both of those things,
and this is something
that will be available
to our Apps partners soon,
if any are in the room here.
What we needed was
we needed to create effectively
a mash-up that allowed
our Apps partners
to be able to have an on-demand
ticket management system--
so, allow them to see
and modify the tickets
that they have
submitted to Google,
support tickets that they have
as well as the tickets
that their customers submitted
directly to Google.
This information was available
across different systems,
and so we had to pull these
together,
and so what we did was,
we created an App Engine app,
with a Google Web Toolkit
user interface.
And so, Google Web Toolkit
allows us to create a nice,
custom user interface
to our own look and feel,
with a nice Ajax
responsiveness.
And then that calls down
into Google App Engine,
which actually pulls the data
from multiple data sources,
and creates the logic
to create the display.
I mentioned this earlier, but
a nice, certainly, end use here,
is we leveraged Google
for authentication
and authorization;
we leveraged Google accounts.
In this case, these are our
partners that are using this.
They already have
Google Apps accounts,
because they're using it to
manage their partner console,
but if you think about it,
any Google Apps customization
you do,
if a customer is using
Google Apps,
they're going to have
Google accounts,
and you want to be able
to leverage that.
You don't want to
have to force them
to create a new username and
password for your custom logic.
Really easy to do that
with App Engine.
So, a nice example,
and it's a very typical example
of Web Toolkit
on top of App Engine.
Okay.
Another option at
the UI layer is Gadgets.
So Gadgets are custom HTML
or JavaScript components,
supportable web applications
that you can then embed
in various webpages
or in Google properties,
Google properties
known as Gadget containers.
So really, it is a way
in which you can customize
the Google Apps UI
through these containers.
So we'll talk about
a few of them.
One of the gadget containers
is Gmail.
So a couple different options
with Gmail,
but one of the things
you can do, simply,
is to have your customers
install a gadget into Gmail
as a sidebar gadget,
and expose your custom HTML
and JavaScript
right within the sidebar,
the margin of Gmail,
which is really convenient,
a convenient access point
for users
who are in Gmail
all day long.
But another,
more powerful example
is Gmail contextual gadgets.
So these are gadgets
that actually live
within email itself,
within an email itself,
and they're triggered to appear
based on clues from that email,
so like, who the email is from,
who it's to,
the content of the message,
and the subject, and so forth.
And then the gadget within
the email can actually
use those clues to provide
a custom interface display,
custom logic,
and so forth.
So really cool, and we have
to look at an example here.
So, Appirio is another
one of our Apps partners,
and they're also
a salesforce.com partner.
So what they noticed
with Salesforce,
with Salesforce CRM,
is that it's really great
for allowing sales reps
to manage
their customer information,
but those same sales reps
are also using Google Apps,
and they tend to spend
a lot of their time
in Google Apps
and in Gmail.
And so they wanted a way to
bring these experiences together
in such a way to accelerate
decision making, and so forth.
And so, what they did was
they created this tool set
called Cloud Works,
which is really meant
to facilitate common
interactions
between applications.
And what we're looking at here,
one of the fruits of this,
is this Gmail contextual gadget
that we're looking at,
so this is a Gmail interface
that we're looking at.
On the top half of the screen
is an email that came in,
and then at the bottom half
here is this contextual gadget
that is surfaced
by Cloud Works,
and what it's doing
is it's looking at--
it appears because of some rule
that was embedded around
who the email was to
and who it was from--
and what it does is it actually
looks into sales calls out
and looks into
Salesforce CRM,
and then pulls appropriate
accounts and opportunities
and contacts and so forth,
surfaces that information
right within the email,
and then not only
allows the user
to see that information
conveniently,
but also allows them to go ahead
and take action
right within the email.
And it's amazing to what degree
this can speed up productivity.
Really nice way to streamline
business processes
and help people
get things done.
So, other types of
gadget containers:
Google Calendar,
similar to Gmail.
You can have sidebar gadgets,
and you can surface
your custom functionality
right there,
particularly functionality
that's temporarily relevant.
But then also, with Calendar,
you can have event gadgets.
So these are gadgets that are
tied to a particular date,
and so you can think of them
as custom events,
essentially, for
a user's calendar.
And so an example here is
that you can integrate
a user's calendar, with, say
a travel reservations system,
and say that the user goes
and creates a reservation
on that system,
their flight times and so forth
show up as events
on their calendar.
Another example
is Google Sites.
A lot of the examples
I talked about earlier
on Apps Script was
actually using Google Sites.
Google Sites is this
collaboration umbrella.
It's a really popular place
to surface user
interface components
for multiple systems,
creating dashboards
and so forth.
And so we saw some examples
where Apps Script forms
are surfaced through
Google Sites.
That was using the Sites Gadgets
framework.
And then, Google Docs is another
interesting piece,
so this is--particularly
Google Spreadsheets.
This actually goes
the other direction,
so you can actually use
a spreadsheet as a data source,
to populate a gadget,
and then that gadget
becomes a custom visualization
of that data.
And then, you can take
that custom visualization,
and export that out to other
websites and properties.
So, a simple example here is,
let's say you have a spreadsheet
of addresses.
You create a custom
visualization,
which is essentially a mapping
view of those addresses,
and then you take that map
and you put it on your website,
and now you have a simple
store locator, for example.
Okay, so last thing
we'll look at.
How are we doing on time?
Last thing we'll look at is
the ability to modify
Google Apps
business objects.
We talked about Google Apps
script quite a bit here,
the ability to add events to
a user's Calendar for example,
but I wanted to touch
on the Google data APIs.
So Google Data APIs
are rest-based APIs
for reading and writing data,
stored by Google Apps.
It's XML sent over HTTP
using common HTTP methods
like "get" and "post".
But then, that's at
the protocol layer,
but then there are
various client libraries
that are built above that
in various languages
to allow users to use these
more conveniently.
There are dozens of
Google Data APIs,
but specifically relating
to Google Apps,
there's more or less
Data APIs associated
with each of the applications
at the application layer,
so allowing users to create
documents programatically,
to create sites and site pages,
to read and write to cells
on a Google spreadsheet,
to add to a Google user's
calendar,
or update a user's contact list
and so forth.
And then at the administrative
layer,
there's a set of options there,
including being able
to create users,
to be able to do
usage reporting,
and things like that.
Okay, so a quick example here
now, of the Google Data APIs,
particular the Google
Spreadsheets API--
and this will actually also
touch on Google Web Toolkit
and Google App Engine as well.
So again, internally
within Google,
we had this need to create
ad hoc performance reports.
So reporting on
partner performance,
or product performance,
or our, like,
marketing campaign
performance,
and so we needed to create
and run these reports,
and then we need to analyze
the data in interesting ways,
including maybe being analyzed
by multiple people.
And so what we did was,
first we used Google Web Toolkit
to create this ad hoc
report-builder interface,
where you can pull the different
fields you want to see,
and the constraints,
and the format you want to see
the result in, and so forth
in Google Web Toolkit.
Then, that calls down into
an App Engine module,
which then calls out into
the various data sources--
Cloud non-premise data sources--
to pull in the data
and then share it
and actually do the work
of generating the report.
But then, the key part is then,
from there, what that does
is that it pushes
that report data
out to a Google spreadsheet,
and this is where
the Google Spreadsheets Data API
comes in.
And the reason why we do that
is because now the end user
can use a spreadsheet
to view the results,
and take advantage of
all the built-in features
and functions
of Google Spreadsheets,
particularly
the rich visualization tools,
charts and gadgets
and so forth,
as well as the sharing model,
the access control model,
to be able to share this
report data, you know,
amongst users.
So it's a nice way of tying
these things together
and a really nice way
of not reinventing the wheel.
Okay, so, with that, what
I'm going to do is pass
it over to David Hoff
from Cloud Sherpas,
and David's going to go
into a little bit more depth
on an example, customer scenario
that Cloud Sherpas recently had.
David:
Thank you, Jeff.
Jeff: Sure.
David: I will wait here.
As Jeff mentioned,
I want to give you
just a very, very brief
introduction into Cloud Sherpas,
so you can understand
the context of our discussion.
I think Jeff pointed out
that there were
kind of three categories:
the MSP,
the ISV, and the SI.
And, Cloud Sherpas
was founded by myself
and a few other partners
about three years ago,
focused on
exactly this trifecta,
so, the ability to provide
managed services,
the ability to build custom
extensions to those services,
and the ability to deploy
everything seamlessly
in an enterprise.
So, what we wanted to do today
is talk a little bit
about a project that we started
about a year ago
for an organization
called CHEP.
And CHEP is a multinational
organization
with roughly around
10,000 users.
And they came to us as part
of their Google Apps deployment
and said, "We have
some large challenges
in regards to a share-point
deployment.
We have multiple
disparate technologies
that are scattered
all over the enterprise."
And these are all typical
on-premise technologies
that took a great deal
of investment to deploy,
but because of the local
nature of each of them,
they didn't effectively reach
the entire organization
as a whole.
So you can see,
I've got up here:
They had pockets of open text,
they had pockets of share point,
and they even had
localized file servers.
So this is one area where,
Jeff, where we can plus one
a little bit to say,
you also have the opportunity
to integrate things like
the Google search appliance.
So this is another great tool
that is in kind of
your developer's toolbox
of things
that can help solve problems.
Ultimately, the discussions
that we had
centered around these
four or five key issues.
There was a significant mismatch
between the tools
that were available
and the information
that the users could access.
So IT was needed for very
simple, simple requests.
If you're on Google Apps,
you're already comfortable
with the fact
that you can go out and
within a click or two,
you can create
a Google site.
Within their organization,
this was roughly
a two-week process,
and it had to go in front
of a governance board
that consisted of people
in different geographies,
and it really slowed down
the process
of disseminating information
in the organization.
In addition
because of this scale,
it made the information
become outdated.
So it was complex,
it was unattended over time,
and one of our applications
directors there at CHEP,
had this quote:
"It was like a large building
with no residents."
And so, we met with them
and we talked about
what their vision
for the Internet was,
and this was the slide
that we all kind of
ultimately agreed upon,
and it was founded
out of two things.
It was founded out of a vision
of what they wanted
to see in their intranet,
but it was also governed by the
reality of what was happening
within their organization.
So what I mean by that is they
had found their users
were already using Google Docs
and using Google Sites.
These were tools that their
end users had picked up
on their own
and found so valuable
that they had gone outside
the scope of the IT department,
so IT had to recognize this,
and figure out a way--
how do we incorporate
all of these collaborative tools
in a way that we feel
comfortable managing it
from an information
technology perspective.
So again, if we started
at the bottom of the pyramid,
that's where Google Docs
comes in.
Anybody can go out
and create Google Docs.
You don't necessarily have
to be a part of Google Apps.
And this is a great entrance
into the technology.
When we go live
with Google Apps,
we now have the ability to bring
all of that under one umbrella.
So it's all within
Google Apps,
and we get extended
functionality with Google Sites.
So that's kind of the
second tier from the bottom,
where we've now introduced
this capability to our users,
to be able to go out
and create Google sites,
with just a click or two,
and this produced a challenge
for their IT organization.
You know, a group
that was comfortable
and in control because
they could approve and deny
the ability to create sites,
has now kind of lost that.
So during our discussions,
we had to back up a little bit
and we had to say, "Why do you
want to control these sites?
What is the business rationale
that makes it valuable for you
to be able to have control
over these sites?"
And as we kind of peeled back
some of the layers of the onion,
it was more a concern
that we don't want people
creating sites and sharing them
externally.
We want to have some control
over the public image,
and the reality is, we really
don't need to get involved,
from an IT perspective,
in the internal creation
of content.
So you can see about
midway up in the pyramid,
we start to have a break.
And then this is where
the IT department
and the governance committee
start to have control
over the content.
So at the very top,
we have things
like the corporate intranet.
We wanted to have
a more structured process
within this content,
so that it's audited,
so that it's logged,
so that it's reviewed
by multiple people before,
you know, someone goes out
and posts,
"Hey, today's a holiday.
Everybody take the day off."
So this was the vision,
and this was the result.
So, you guys think this is
a good-looking Google site?
Clap if you want.
I personally love it.
I think this is a beautiful
example of what you can do
with Google Sites.
So often, people get kind of
in the daily grind
of just creating a site
and not building a template,
and they wind up
with the left-hand nav,
and it just has
a very common flavor to it.
What we set out to do here
was build something
that not only was
very, very useful,
but it was also
very visually appealing,
and if you were to see
this actually live,
you would see that there are
animations going on,
there is an embedded MP3
that gives you a verbal
walk-through of the intranet.
You would see that we have got
actionable quick links
that are in that little
drop-down menu.
The name of their intranet
is Walter,
so they gave it
a little personalization.
And again, this is
another opportunity for you
as application developers
to get involved
and bring some new I-skills
to make something
that is very visually
attractive.
What we're going to do from here
is we're going to dig in
to some of the content elements
that build up this page,
some of the gadgets.
So we kind of came up with
this idea of managed gadgets.
How many of you guys
in the room
could write
a piece of JavaScript
that said "Hello, world"?
Okay.
So everybody look around
at the folks
that have their hands up.
These are the people that can
build you custom gadgets.
If you can write "Hello, world"
in JavaScript,
that's all you need to know
how to do.
And the great thing about that
is, gadgets are what give you
the capability to build
dynamic content in Google Sites.
It's part of the security
infrastructure
that you can't just go
embedding dynamic stuff
in the regular HTML
of the Google site.
Gadgets gives you
that capability
and that flexibility.
What's also nice about Gadgets
is they're centrally controlled
and centrally managed.
So when you work
with an organization
and they say, perhaps,
"I don't want to see
a particular gadget available
to my users," right?
In a Google Apps environment,
we can go turn those gadgets
on and off.
Furthermore, we can
start to create things
like private gadgets.
Let's say you have a gadget
that's an SAP orders fee.
You want to be able
to take that gadget
and you want to expose it
to your users.
This now becomes
kind of a managed gadget
within your organization
that takes all the complexity
out of building you know
an SAP portlet if you will,
and puts it
right into the power
and right into the hands
of an end user.
So the centrally managed feature
is a huge value,
and really what that provides
is consistent content.
So if you've ever tried to build
a large-scale
Google Sites project,
you'll notice that that can be
a bit of a challenge,
to have one piece of content
that is presented
in multiple Google sites.
And that's the ideal situation
to use a Google gadget.
So, if we go out
and we create one gadget,
we can publish that
in multiple sites,
and then a single update
to the source of that gadget
is now automatically
disseminated
into all the various places
that are consuming that content.
So I'm going to zoom in
a little bit.
This is the top half
of the intranet page
that you were looking at,
and we're going to dissect it
a little bit.
We can see,
I mentioned
that there was
an embedded audio file.
So in the upper left corner,
we see Walter.
There is actually an embedded
audio player
that's available
to the user.
Right below that,
there's the quick links,
and again this is something
that is managed centrally,
so if they want to update
a quick link
into any of the applications
that are using it,
it's going to get published
out to all those sites.
On the "Jim Ritchie's Blog"
corner,
this is a flash animation.
You might notice the series of,
I think, five green boxes.
It scrolls
from left to right
with rotating banner
announcements through it,
promoting different things
within the organization.
So again, this is just
another gadget.
In this case,
it's a very simple gadget
that is really
just an I-frame.
It allows you to bring in
some rich visual content
into the homepage.
A little further down,
we have breaking news,
and again, this is another
great way to use gadgets.
We publish multiple feeds,
so feeds that are
contextually relevant
to different individuals
within the organization.
So let's say that I work
in a plant in Sydney,
and it's a manufacturing
plant.
I could have news
that is tailored to me,
versus if I'm a truck driver
and I work for one of the plants
in the Americas.
So, again, a gadget is
a great consumer of that feed.
The last one on the top half
of that page
is called People Search,
and we're going to dig a little
further into that gadget
and kind of how it works.
So if you were to look
at that same exact page
that we just looked
at above the fold,
this is what happens if you
throw that same Google site page
into edit mode.
All you see are gadgets.
You see, I think there's
two hard-coded links at the top.
One is to edit
your profile information,
and the other is to switch to
one of the sister companies'
intranets, but everything else
on this page is dynamic.
So you can see the logo gadget
that we've got there.
Again, a great capability
to reuse content.
We've got the quick links gadget
that I mentioned
that allows you to publish URLs,
you know,
consistently from
a central console.
The news and the video,
and then finally down in the
lower right, the People Search.
And I'm just going to advance
a little bit
and step into People Search.
This is, again, one of many
of the components
that builds out the intranet,
and at Cloud Sherpas,
we're a pure-play Google shop,
so pretty much everything we do
is using a Google technology,
and I think People Search
touches on just about
every one of them.
So, People Search is actually
a Google App Engine application.
And for the user interface,
it uses GWT.
This is again,
as Jeff was mentioning,
a great user interface
technology
that gives you a lot
of flexibility in presentation
between, you know, a browser
and a mobile device.
The great part about all this
is that it's reusable,
so you saw the one screen shot
of it,
there in the homepage
of the intranet,
but it's also used
in other places
within individual Google sites,
regional sites,
and departmental sites.
The one area that CHEP came back
and they said,
"We want a very, very robust
search infrastructure."
And as you know, search comes
as part of Google Sites,
but the challenge there
was a little bigger.
In addition to migrating content
out of their other repositories
into Google Sites,
we also had the challenge
of their local file systems,
and this is where
we were able to integrate
Google Search,
specifically the Google
Search appliance,
to index all of their
local file servers,
and aggregate and federate
all that content
with everything
that you're seeing here.
So, when we start
talking about search,
we can go in and use People
Search to locate an individual.
And as part of the result set,
we're also going to see content
that is associated
with that individual.
So part of this is going to be
a directory profile
about that individual,
information that's pulled
from active directory
in this case,
and part of it is going
to be information
that the use
has self-edited.
So, you remember
at the very top,
in the upper right corner
of the intranet,
there was
an "edit my profile" page.
And what this allows
the end users to do,
they can click on that link,
and they can fill in
some of the information
about themselves
directly in the directory.
Now, we've got several fields
that are locked down
and not available for the user
to edit,
but for the ones that they can,
it's relatively free-form,
and they can enter
particular skill sets,
particular industries,
anything about them
that might be relevant
in the context of a search.
So one of the last
Google technologies,
and I'd highly encourage you
guys to take a look at this one.
It is something that you can
build out of the box
in probably about
ten minutes.
It's the Google
Visualizations API.
And we did that to build
a dynamic org chart,
and if you want, I challenge you
after the session
to go out and create
a Google spreadsheet
and insert the visualizations
org chart component,
and what it will allow you to do
is very quickly
take that spreadsheet,
and display it
just as you see here
with the dynamic org chart.
So it's a very powerful
technology,
and I'll step in a little
further with People Search.
And again, stick around
for questions.
We'll have some Q&A
at the end of the session.
But from a people search
perspective,
the data flows--
everything starts
in Active Directory.
And from Active Directory,
we use a tool that's provided
as part of Google Apps, called
Google Apps Directory Sync.
It's a free tool,
and it allows a one-way push
from Active Directory
to your Google user profiles.
So if you have an existing
set of phone numbers,
of fax numbers, of locations,
of all this data,
using the GADS tool,
you can seamlessly push that
into your Google
user profiles.
So that's the first step
in the chain.
The next step is to take all of
that user profile information
and feed it into our
App Engine application.
So here we're using
the Google APIs,
specifically
the user profile API,
to programatically
retrieve all that information
that originally started
in Active Directory.
It moved into Google Profiles,
and now we're pulling it
into our app, and from there,
we expose that information
and allow the user
to augment it
with some additional fields.
So they can do direct self-edits
of this personal data,
and we all have confidence
that we're not going to corrupt
Active Directory,
and we're not going to
create any infrastructure
challenges for the IT team.
The last result in this entire
chain of events is,
we take all that information
that we've aggregated,
and we publish it
as a direct feed
to a Google search appliance.
All that results
in the search screen
that you see
down at the bottom,
where we've queried
for a particular user,
and we can start
to see their photo,
we can start to see
their profile information,
we can even seen content
associated
with those individuals.
We talked a little bit
about the pyramid,
and I'm not going to go
into a great deal of depth here,
but I highly
encourage everyone--
there's a session tomorrow
that's going to talk about
Google Apps Script
and work flow processes,
and this is essentially
what we have here
for the Google Sites
creation work flow.
Again, if you think
of the bottom of that pyramid,
we wanted to give the ability
for users to create user sites
but we needed an approval
process to promote that site
up into the upper echelon
of the pyramid.
And this is how
it's accomplished.
So the user goes out,
and they click a link
to get their site approved.
In this case
I'm creating a new site
from one of the company-approved
templates.
And this is a nice place
to use App Script.
We've got the ability to say,
there may be a whole bunch
of templates out there,
but only a handful of them
are sanctioned for use
kind of in this upper echelon
of the pyramid.
So my App Script
reads the templates,
and filters out just the ones
that are appropriate.
All of this is routed
through email,
and the results are actually
managed in a Google spreadsheet.
And a Google spreadsheet
is a great container
for keeping
all of this information
when you're building
these work flows.
So, a couple of lessons learned:
in this project,
it's essential to involve
stakeholders,
and it's essential
to keep them involved,
and build a regular
release cycle
of getting this information
out to users.
Google Apps is constantly
introducing new features,
so you need to prioritize.
What is it
that we need to go live,
and what are the nice-to-have
things that we can roll in?
And maybe Google
even will release those
as native features.
Another lesson learned:
you're going to be,
especially in a large
enterprise environment,
promoting this content
between your various production
and staging sites
on a regular basis,
so make sure you build
a consistent process
to get that content published,
and that's going to facilitate
releasing that content
on a regular basis.
So automate that process,
make it easier for everyone,
so that when you're ready
to say,
"Hey, take a look
at the new version,"
everybody's got it.
I mentioned gadgets.
Everything in Sites that
you want to do dynamically
is going to require gadgets,
so go ahead and invest some time
in learning
Google Gadgets.
I would especially recommend
looking at the open
social containers,
these give you
a lot more flexibility.
If you haven't started
building gadgets yet,
it's very easy.
Go out and Google it,
but you'll see
there's an IDE that's right
in the browser,
so you can actually go to
a webpage, build a gadget,
and start with
something simple.
Just build a gadget
that has quick links,
or URLs to other applications.
An additional lesson learned
is, register a master user
for all of your projects
within Google Apps.
So, create a Google Apps account
that's dedicated to owning
all of this content,
and that way
you don't have to worry
as much about changes
in developers
and who's working on what.
You know all the security
permissions will be accurate
for this master administrator.
Finally, App Engine
is the ideal hosting platform
for all of these
custom gadgets.
So in this organization
they were moving away
from on-premise infrastructure,
and as you start to build
a lot of these gadgets,
you need a place
to put them.
You need a place for
those applications to live.
And App Engine
is perfect for that.
It's pre-built
and ready to go.
And finally, consider and test
security at every phase.
From time to time,
you'll want to understand
the security models
around a gadget,
and how the content is displayed
in regards to authentication.
So, in multi-domain
environments,
this becomes an even more
important consideration.
Look at your users
from the different organizations
within Google Apps,
and make sure
that they have access
to the content that they need.
So again, I appreciate
everyone's time,
and I think we'll
turn it over now to Q&A.
If you could,
there's a microphone back here,
and if you could step up
to the microphone
when you have questions,
and...
Jeff: Perfect. Thank you.
[applause]
Or hands.
That'll work as well.
man: The question is--
is this on?
David:
Yep.
man: Just waiting
for the crowd to clear.
I think people are smelling
food or something.
The question I have is about
contextual gadgets.
There was an indication
of custom content extractors,
but they're not available,
and it's been there forever
saying they will be available
at some point.
Is there any idea of when
custom content extractors
will be available,
or we could write our own?
David: When you say
that custom content extractors
should be there now,
is there a specific use case?
man: Well, for example,
I might, in an email message,
want to extract something
out of a header
that's not currently
available.
Currently I can extract
the subject, the from,
the to, things like that,
but there might be
something else
I want to extract
out of a header
and currently
I'm just limited
to the pre-defined
content extractors,
but there's a note there
on the page that says
they will be available
at some point, custom,
that you can write your own,
but I haven't seen
any change to that,
so I just wondered
if there's any word
about if developers
will be able to write
our own custom content
extractors.
David: Good question, and it may
be something more for--
Jeff:
Yeah, and I can just say,
certainly these Gmail contextual
gadgets, I think they're not--
they haven't been in use.
We haven't done a really great
job of marketing them
even to the developer
community.
I think they're a lot more
powerful than people realize.
But having said that,
and what that means is,
that we are still investing
quite a bit in expanding that,
and also these
additional extractors
and the ability to do
custom content extractors
is one kind of axes.
Another way
is more flexible ways
to install and acquire
these contextual Gmail gadgets.
So there is development work
going on.
I don't know
the specific status of that,
but it's actively
being built out for sure.
man:
Okay. Thank you.
man: Hi.
Great example of an intranet.
What I was wondering about is
statement of the empty building.
How did you convince business
sort of people
who had to pay to rebuild
everything?
David:
Say that again.
man:
Assuming the empty building?
Assuming everything
has been built,
but nobody's been using
the applications
or the existing intranet.
How did you get sponsored?
David:
How did we get sponsored?
man:
Yeah.
David: Actually,
that was relatively easy.
This particular customer
was in the midst of looking
at a share point deployment,
which had a very, very
significant price tag,
and in comparison
to Google Apps,
since Google Apps was already
part of the messaging plan,
it was essentially
a no-cost addition,
so it was more about being able
to prove to the customer
that we could provide all
the functionality they needed
within the Google Sites
container,
so they had a list of
probably 18 core tenets
that they wanted to see,
and we took a few days,
built up some mock-ups,
some wire-frames,
and some demos,
and showed them that yes,
we could indeed
embed the types of content.
Once we were able
to do that,
they were solely caring
about function,
and it made the rest of the
decisions kind of a no-brainer.
But it did take some executive
commitment and sponsorship,
and I certainly would suggest
to everyone that that is an area
that you want to spend time on,
you know,
showing people
sophisticated sites,
and getting that commitment
from the executive group.
man: You did that
as a commercial effort?
The first demo?
David:
Say that again?
man: Did you do that
as a commercial effort,
from your company's side,
to do the first initial days,
or was that already
part of the paid produce?
David: I didn't quite
pick up on that.
man: So you have to demonstrate
somehow your skills?
David:
Yeah.
man: Is that part of
your commercial offering
before you start getting paid,
or is that--?
David: Absolutely.
So, we created an--
my Internet access
is a little slow here,
but I could show you
the demo site that we created
that addressed
these 18 core tenets,
and we went in front
of their governance board.
We showed them how,
in most cases--
I mean, I think
we had three days
to put together the demo site,
but as we went through it,
we showed them how we could
address the core requirements,
and then for the things
that took a little more effort,
we kind of scoped out
what they would look like
and built some wire frames.
Jeff:
And that can certainly vary
depending on
the customer segment.
They're working with,
what was it?
6,000 employees,
or something?
David: Yeah.
Jeff: It'll certainly vary.
It'll certainly vary
if you're working
with a small business.
Often their partners wind up
being the trusted advisor,
and it's basically saying,
"Look, here's the way
that we can address
your business problems,
the business problems
and objectives that you have."
Don't worry about the fact
that it's Google Apps
and other technologies
behind the scenes,
but when you're positioned
as a true solution provider,
then whether it's bringing
the technology to bear
and implementing,
or it's actually developing,
custom solutions,
there's kind of much more
of a gray area there.
And so you're able
to build out solutions
and make proposals
to customers more easily.
David: And existing content
is a great way,
so if you build
a reference site, you know,
because it's Google Sites,
it doesn't cost you anything,
and you can use
that in your sales process
over and over again,
so, you know,
throw a few gadgets in there,
make sure people understand
and get the vision of what
you can do with the platform.
Jeff:
Okay.
If there are no more questions,
we'll let people go to lunch,
but thank you,
thank you again for joining.